THIS IS "THE FIVE."
THE LIBERAL MEDIA OF FREAKING
OUT AFTER GETTING JUST A TINY
TASTE OF CENSORSHIP.
ELON MUSK GOING ON A LATE NIGHT
MASSACRE TEMPORARILY SUSPENDING
ACCOUNTS OF LEFT-WING REPORTERS
FROM "THE NEW YORK TIMES," CNN
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST."
HE EVEN GAVE A LITTLE TIME OUT
TO THE GUY WHO USED TO BE KEITH
OLBERMANN AND HE CLAIMS DOXXED
HIM WITH ASSASSINATION
COORDINATES BY SHARING AN
ACCOUNT THAT ATTRACTS DAVID JETT
IN REAL TIME.
THE BILLIONAIRE WITH AN INSTANT
IN L.A. WHERE A STALKER JUMPED
ON THE TOP OF HIS CAR AND HIS
KID WAS IN AND SAID THIS --
>> INFORMATION ABOUT SOMEBODY'S
LOCATION IS INAPPROPRIATE AND I
THINK EVERYONE WOULD NOT LIKE
THAT TO BE DONE TO THEM HERE OR
THERE WILL NOT BE ANY
DISTINCTION IN THE FUTURE WITH
JOURNALIST AND REGULAR PEOPLE.
EVERYBODY WILL BE QUICK TO SAY
IT BUT THEY ARE NOT SPECIAL
SIZED JOURNALIST.
>> Jesse: AOC IS REALLY MAD
SAYING THIS, "I GET FEELING
UNSAFE BUT THE ABUSE OF POWER
AND FRANTICALLY ENTERING AND
JOURNALIST.
TAKE A BEAT AND LAY OFF THE PORT
OF FASCISM PURE TRIED TO PUT
DOWN YOUR PHONE."
IN THE SAME MEANING BEYOND THE
CENSORSHIP WITH THE HUNTER BIDEN
LAPTOP STORY ALL OF A SUDDEN
MELTING DOWN, WATCH.
>> THIS SEEMS REALLY SCARY,
OKAY?
>> THE CHAOS, THE EGO, THE
INSULTS AND THE FACT THAT HE IS
BRINGING DOWN AN INSTITUTION.
TWITTER IS NOT THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY, BUT IT CERTAINLY FEELS
LIKE THE DYING DAYS OF THIS
PLATFORM UNLESS SOMETHING
CHANGES QUICKLY.
>> I THINK THIS RAISES A BIG
QUESTION THE FREE PRESS, THE
FUTURE OF THE FREE PRESS ON
TWITTER LOOKS LIKE.
>> I WORRY ABOUT THE CHILLING
EFFECT THIS MIGHT HAVE ON THOSE
REPORTERS, PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU
THINK MUSK AND OTHER COMPANIES
BASED, TESLA, YOUR REPORTING ON
WORKING CONDITIONS.
>> Jesse: JESSICA TARLOV
CANNOT WAIT TO TALK ABOUT THIS
STORY.
WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO SAY?
>> Jessica: I WOULD LIKE TO
SAY THAT I THINK ELON MUSK NEEDS
A CONTENT MODERATION TEAM HERE
THAT HE NEEDS A TRUST AND SAFETY
COUNCIL TO COME BACK SO THAT
PEOPLE COULD ACTUALLY SEE THERE
WERE FOLKS AND NOT JUST ONE ONEN
DECIDING HIS FEELINGS GOT HURT
WHERE HE FELT UNSAFE EVEN THOUGH
THE ELON JET ACCOUNT IS PUBLIC
AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT THAT.
THE ASSASSINATION ATTEMPT ON HIS
CHILD.
IT IS SCARY WHEN SOMEONE HAS
YOUR KID IN THERE.
HE DIDN'T REPORT IT TO THE
PLACE, WHICH SEEMS STRANGE.
DONNIE O'SULLIVAN ON TWITTER
JUST WEEDING OUT THE FACT THAT
THE L.A.P.D. SAID HE DIDN'T FILE
A REPORT.
IT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH HIS
COORDINATES WERE ASSASSINATION
AT ALL.
IN THE TRANSITION FROM
REPUBLICANS BEING UP IN ARMS
ABOUT PRESERVING THE
FIRST AMENDMENT TO CRY HARDER
LIVES IS REALLY SOMETHING TO
BEHOLD.
SO HE CHANGES THE TERMS OF
SERVICE A COUPLE OF DAYS AGO TO
SHUT DOWN THE JETT TRACK WHICH
EXPLICITLY SAID I WOULD NEVER
SHUT DOWN THE PIER THE NEW TERMS
OF SERVICE ARE SO VAGUE, JESSE,
I TOOK YOUR PICTURE RIGHT NOW.
>> Jesse: NOW TRY IT.
>> Jessica: AND I POSTED IT
ON TWITTER.
THE GEOLOCATION OF THAT WOULD
QUALIFY AS A VIOLATION OF THE
TERMS AND SERVICE.
SO, I COULD BE SUSPENDED FROM
TWITTER FOR HARMING YOU FOR
RIGHT NOW JUST USING WHAT IS AND
THIS APP.
>> Jesse: SO YOU ARE
COMPLAINING TO THE TERMS ARE
ARBITRARY?
>> Jessica: NO, I'M NOT DONE.
>> Jesse: CONTINUE.
>> Jessica: HE IS SUSPENDING
PEOPLE WHO ARE AGGRAVATING HIM
OR HURTING HIS FEELINGS LIKE
LOPEZ FROM BUSINESS INSIDER WHO
HAS BEEN WITH HIM FOR YEARS
BECAUSE TESLA, THE COMPANY SHE
COVERS.
SHE GOT SUSPENDED FOR PUTTING UP
OLD INFORMATION ABOUT HIM ABOUT
ELON MUSK HAS A HABIT OF TALKING
TO MIKE DOXXING PEOPLE SHE
DOESN'T LIKE FROM THE PAST.
SHE'S OFF.
IF YOU HEAR ABOUT THE
FIRST AMENDMENT YOU SHOULD BE UP
IN ARMS ABOUT THIS ESPECIALLY
THE FACT HE DOESN'T HAVE A
COMMITTEE OF PEOPLE PAYING
ATTENTION --
>> Sandra: WHAT IS THAT GOING
TO DO A FEW PUBLIC A PICTURE OF
JESSIE, WILL THE TEAM EXPLORE --
>> Jessica: HE DOESN'T HAVE
ONE.
>> Sandra: I WOULD TAKE IT A
STEP FURTHER.
JUST BE PRETTY TRANSPARENT WITH
THE RULES.
OBVIOUSLY WHAT HE DECIDED HE DID
TWEET THIS OUT AND JOURNALIST
ACTUALLY REFERENCE BACK TO THIS.
BUT ELONVA SAID IN THE ACCOUNT
DOXXING REAL-TIME INFORMATION ON
ANY ONE WILL BE SUSPENDED
BECAUSE TWITTER CONSIDERS THAT A
PHYSICAL SAFETY VIOLATION
INCLUDING POSTING LINKS TO
REAL-TIME LOCATION INFO.
ON A SLIGHTLY DAILY BASIS, YOU
WILL NOT BE BANNED FOR THAT.
THIS IS REAL-TIME INFORMATION.
SO FINE, HAVE THE CONTENT
MODERATION.
BUT HAVE THE RULES, SPELL THE
RULES OUT IN REFERENCE BACK TO
THEM WHEN SOMEBODY'S BAND.
I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WILL TAKE
ISSUE WITH SOMEBODY RUNNING A
COMPANY THAT MAKES THAT
DECISION.
THE ONE OFF DECISION BY
ELON MUSK IS WHAT EVERYBODY IS
TAKING ISSUE WITH.
>> Will: JESSICA, YOUR
SALES PITCH IS ELON MUSK SHOULD
ADOPT CONTENT MODERATION TEAM
BECAUSE IT WOULD BE LESS
BARBITURATE AND OPAQUE WHAT WE
HAVE LIVED UNDER THE PAST FOUR
OR FIVE YEARS?
TWITTER HEAD CONTENT MODERATION
TEAM.
IT SILENCED PEOPLE FOR ANY HOST
OF REASONS THEY WANTED ANY GIVEN
MOMENT OR ANY SUGGESTION BY THE
FBI.
NOT JUST CONSERVATIVES.
HOW ABOUT DR. JAY BACTERIA FROM
THE LATEST COVID ORTHODOX.
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING IS LET'S
GO BACK TO THE WAY IT WAS.
I WILL NOT SEE HER AND TELL YOU
TODAY ELON MUSK EXERCISING
ARBITRARY POWER IS PER PERFECT.
BUT PLEASE DON'T SELL WHAT WE
HAVE BEFORE IS BETTER.
I BELIEVE IN FREE SPEECH AND I
BELIEVE FREE SPEECH IS ALWAYS
BETTER.
ELON SAID HIS LINE IS DOXED.
BY THE WAY HIS INFORMATION WAS
NOT PUBLIC BUT PRIVATE.
SPACE >> Jessica: THAT IS NOT
TRUE.
>> Jesse: THE FAA GIVES HIM A
NEW PLANE IDENTIFIER EVERY MONTH
BECAUSE OF THREATS TO HIS
SAFETY.
BUT THIS GUY, THIS MUSK TRACKER
WROTE SOFTWARE TO HACK IT SO
COULD GET AROUND THAT.
SO, IT IS NOT JUST PUBLICLY
AVAILABLE INFORMATION.
THE GUY IS A CREEP.
>> Jessica: SURE, OKAY, BUT IF
YOU ARE TRYING TO ASSASSINATE
ELON MUSK OR STEAL HIS CHILD,
WHICH IS WHAT HE IS ALLEGING,
YOU KNOW HOW TO GET THAT
INFORMATION BESIDES GOING
ON TWITTER AND CLICKING ON WHAT
ELON JET HAS TO SAY.
AND THAT INVESTIGATION --
>> Jesse: SO LET'S NOT MAKE IT
EASIER TO BE ON A PLATFORM THAT
HE OWNS, RIGHT?
JUST LIKE YOU WOULDN'T WANT
PEOPLE TO KNOW WHERE YOU WORK --
ACTUALLY THEY KNOW WHERE YOU'RE
AT 6:00 EVERY SINGLE DAY.
BUT BESIDES THAT, YOU DON'T WANT
THAT.
>> Dagen: I LOVE THE BAWLING
AND HOWLING AT THESE JOURNALISTS
WHO'VE IGNORED ALL OF THESE
TWITTER FILES LIKE
"THE NEW YORK TIMES."
IT WAS RIGHT ON THE WEB PAGE
ABOUT MUSK, TWITTER AND BANNING
THE JOURNALIST.
THEY EVEN COVER THESE TWITTER
FILE DOCS AT ALL.
"THE WASHINGTON POST," LIVE
THEM, THOSE NEFARIOUS GOING ON
SCUM OF THE CENSORSHIP THE
ELECTION INTERFERENCE, BUT NOW
THIS IS NEWSWORTHY BECAUSE THEY
ARE THE STORY!
I LOVE IT.
BUT I AM NOT SURPRISED.
THE ONLY THING I'M SURPRISED
ABOUT WITH ELON MUSK IS THAT HE
DIDN'T START DOING THIS SOONER.
HE SPENT $44 BILLION ON THIS
MONEY LOSING SEWAGE LAGOON.
JESSE, YOU UNDERSTAND THIS.
DO YOU KNOW HOW BAD PEOPLE WINE
AND BEHAVE WHEN THEY PAY FOR A
FULL PRICE FIRST CLASS AIRLINE
TICKET?
CAN YOU IMAGINE SPENDING
$44 BILLION ON THIS HEAP OF
CRAP?
HE SELLING TEST WAS TALK TO PROP
IT UP.
HE SOLD MORE THAN $3.5 BILLION
IN TESLA STOCK RECENTLY.
$23 BILLION WORTH OF TEST.
THIS YEAR.
TESLA STOCK FELL 16% IN THE LAST
FIVE DAYS.
IT'S LIKE A MULTIYEAR LOW.
AND HE HAS TO EXTRACT SOME
PLEASURE OUT OF THIS NIGHTMARE.
SO, WHAT IS THE POINT OF HAVING
ALL THAT MONEY IF YOU CAN'T
THROW YOUR WEIGHT AROUND AND
PANDER SOME PEOPLE THAT YOU FIND
WORK SOME?
THAT IS ALL HE'S DOING.
HE IS A BENEVOLENT CASE.
WAIT UNTIL HE GOES AFTER PEOPLE
HE DOESN'T LIKE.
LISTEN, WE KNOW HOW COME I LIKE,
CRAZY RICH PEOPLE CONNECT.
HE'S NOT EVEN CLOSE TO HOWARD
USE.
>> Will: I FOR ONE WANT TO
BRING BACK KEITH OLBERMANN
DELETE IMMEDIATELY.
LIVE STREAM OVER THE FEW HOURS.
THE BEST JOB HE'S EVER HAD AND
NOW JOBS HE HASN'T HAD.
>> Jessica: I KNOW THAT IS
FUNNY TO MAKE FAIR TO MAKE FUN
OF KEITH OLBERMANN BUT BEFORE WE
GO TO THE BREAK WE MOVE FROM
SAVIOR OF FIRST AMENDMENT TO
SORT OF DECENT WHATEVER DICTATOR
APPEAR THAT IS COOL?
>> Dagen: I THINK ALL OF THESE
PEOPLE SHOULD BE BROUGHT BACK ON
THE PLATFORM, BUT IT'S NOT IN
ELON'S WORLD IT IS NOT
FREE SPEECH.
IT IS SPEECH FREE.
>> Jessica: I DIDN'T GET THAT
MEMO.
>> Jesse: SHE IS SAYING IT
COMES BACK IN SEVEN DAYS, THEY
WILL BE BACK AND THEY BROKE THE
RULE.
THEY KNEW THE ROLE.
THEY BROKE THE RULE.
THEY WERE SUSPENDED AND WILL
COME BACK.
IT'S NOT SO BAD.
NOW, THEY KNOW THE RULES SO THEY
WON'T BREAK IT AGAIN.
THE RULES THAT KAMALA HARRIS
TALKS ABOUT.
WE HAVE TO HAVE RULES AND NORMS.
>> Jessica: NOW WE WILL TALK
ABOUT KAMALA HARRIS AND WILL NOT
DEAL WITH THE TOPIC AT HAND.
WHY IS THAT YOU HAVEN'T BEEN TO
THE BORDER?
>> Dagen: MUSK WALKED OFF AN
INTERVIEW WITH ME YEARS AGO.
>> Will: THESE MATTER BUT THE
PAST FOR ONE STUDENT?
>> Jessica: THEY DID SO WE
READ THE TWITTER FILES AND THEY
WERE COVERED BUT THE PEOPLE
DIDN'T LIKE THE COVERAGE BECAUSE
THERE WAS NOTHING TO IT.
JERRY FROM
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" WROTE
ABOUT IT.
HE SAID THE PEOPLE ARE NOT UP IN
ARMS AND TREY GOWDY SET ON A
SPECIAL REPORT EARLIER.
>> THEY WERE ASSUMED.
>> Jessica: I'M SORRY --
>> Jesse: THE PROOF IS IN THE
PUDDING.
>> Jessica: THE RATIONALE BACK
AND FORTH ABOUT WHY DONALD TRUMP
WAS SUSPENDED.
RIGHT?
PEOPLE HAVING A REAL DEBATE,
PEOPLE ACTUALLY CARED ABOUT
HEAVENLY, INCITING A RIOT.
>> Jesse: THIS IS THE HILL YOU
WANT TO DIE ON, DOXXING PEOPLE?
COME ON, YOU ARE BETTER THAN
THAT.
>> Jessica: MAYBE I'M NOT.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dagen: CAN I SAY ONE QUICK
THING?
HE WALKED OFF OF AN INTERVIEW
WITH ME.
THAT IS WHY HE'S MAD.
AND HE TOOK HIS MICROPHONE OFF
AND THREW IT DOWN.
AND WE WERE TAPING THE INTERVIEW
AND I CALLED HIM A JERK FOR
YEARS.
SO HE CAN MAKE AMENDS.
>> Will: HE BEING ELON.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE HIM TO MAKE
AMENDS?
>> Dagen: HE CAN COME ON FOX
AND DO AN INTERVIE